we just caught our first chief creative
officer I spent six months trying to
find the person that and this was the
order of what mattered to me first
emotional intelligence when I tell you
that I don't respect talent it would
upset you
it's stunning when I run my business how
secondary pure talent is to people's
skills this notion that some creative is
so [ __ ] special that they can be a
douchebag and [ __ ] up the entire place
is the stupidest [ __ ] I've ever heard in
my life and I'm very unpopular in tech
land I did it again at South by where I
was like [ __ ] Steve Jobs I don't want to
run an injustice we're being mean brings
the best that I don't give a [ __ ] if
you're a creative genius [ __ ] act
like a normal person you [ __ ]
I believe continuity trumps everything
continuity you know just like sports a
team that stays together usually beats a
team with superstars that were put
together for one season and I believe
that and I love continuity at Vayner we
have enormous continuity already for a
young company and I want to keep it
forever because I give a [ __ ]
Rice's now living in London like she's
gonna be part of London team because
four years ago when she started working
for him like what do you want you like I
want to be in London when I'm like who
where we go there you'll go there and
then I did it like you do like and by
the way I don't care if you're driven by
money or by work-life balance or by
creative output I individually at 650
care about what you care about and I
also know when you get married you're
gonna care about different [ __ ] what you
know so we are an HR driven organization
I needed to find a CCO that kit
understood that so that was a challenge
when you know especially when you're
looking from and I was looking for
somebody from a world like this because
I wanted to taste what a seasoned
veteran from a widened from a crisp and
you know from look like you know what
would that feel like internally